what's up guys got a little bit of a
tickle in mah wickel if you know what
I'm saying but that ain't gonna stop us
we're talking to a fella that only got
one nut in his sack Oh half Sakka we got
high altitude skeet issues and one of my
favorite movies family man welcome to
this past weekend this past weekend
[Music]
what's up guys is June 26
never places
seven fame is
[Music]
staying with this song for this dude
I kind of wish that's that that lyric
was let's all have some fun while we're
alive that would really be something
ideal to listen to for me for today I'm
feeling good about being alive I hope
you guys are welcome to this past
weekend it is Monday June 26 as we're
getting late into June and I appreciate
you guys being here with me today this
weekend I was lost up the past few days
in Phoenix now Phoenix is a hot City and
known if you spend time in the heat but
I mean I remember being there because I
attended University of Arizona for a
while and I actually went to high school
for a little bit out in Arizona as well
for a semester of high school and they
had a lot of Mexican kids that would
fistfight each other and and and beat
each other up in an abandoned car wash
near the campus of the high school I was
attending Santa Rita high school and
they also had they had they had these
alarms that would go off when different
gangs would threaten each other or fight
each other and everybody was always
spray-painting everything it was it was
fun but it was also just different than
what I was used to in Louisiana and in
the environment I'd grown up in but yeah
I spent some time out there so I was
back in Arizona was in Phoenix this time
in Phoenix is it's nice man it's really
and it was hot it was I mean I think it
was honestly 108 degrees or something
someone melted I think they were looking
for somebody and they found them in a
puddle and that was that you know I mean
that's not candle country you can't have
outdoor candles there because they'll
just they're gone they're gone but after
that I went over to New York City
directly there on Friday and that was a
good time man
did anything else happened on Thursday
oh I was at the Chive
had a had an event and we did a comedy
show there at the stand-up live downtown
in Phoenix and a lot of people came out
this one guy he was kind of like an
alcoholic and I and this dude kind of
cornered me I had a couple conversations
with some nice people men and women but
this other fella kind of cornered me was
all tatted up and he just kept talking
to me about comedy and said he wanted to
do comedy and at a certain point
sometimes I don't like it when like I'm
trying to be a decent listener a
communicator and then somebody just
taken advantage of my time yappin and
this dude had a little he was a little
bit liquid around my lips and so he
would every now and then something fly
over into my face you know and I'm
catching bits and pieces of uh of
moisture and atmosphere off of his face
and that kind of just got under my skin
you know because he's so wasted he
doesn't know that we don't really have a
conversation it's just him saying [ __ ]
over and over again and and me having to
listen to it so I don't like it when
people you know monopolize a
conversation to the point where it's not
it's not even fun to be a listener to be
an active participant in that
conversation but whatever that's the
worst [ __ ] that happened to me that was
hit otherwise we had a great comedy show
I met some cool cats out there as well
in Phoenix my voice is going I don't
know what happened to what I'm going to
left it on the road I did a lot of
traveling here in the past few days but
I'm happy to be with you guys man I got
to New York City and and I like getting
to New York man you just feel there's
energy everywhere there was a
transvestite that was kind of dancing
and beatboxing and had an umbrella open
and that was kind of cool to see I saw I
saw a man take an awning down that had
been up for a long time and there was a
bunch of dead birds and animals and
leaves on it and so that was crazy it
was almost like a little coffin that
he'd opened up that he didn't realize
and they all came falling down and
you know kind of surprised everybody
sort of the dead kind of striking back
surprising everybody long after they'd
been dead a lot of these birds and what
else I wasn't man hasn't shows that
Gotham I appreciate everybody that came
out we had a good time man met some met
some uh some more alcoholics but I met
some people from England
and they were nice and friendly and it
the British I've never been a huge fan
of the British and I'll tell you
straight up we beat them a couple times
and I don't understand why a lot of them
are still milling around over here you
know it's uh and they're good I mean one
on one you know it's different but when
it comes to teams I'm not going to not
on the British side and I think a lot of
the world still gets in a lot of places
in the world still get blamed for a lot
of things the British started you know
you look at the some of the slave trade
the British really were handily in that
and we're over here still dealing with a
lot of the repercussions of slavery and
stuff like that even though the British
were running around slang in slaves okay
so sometimes when I'm meet someone who's
a descendant of a slave you know maybe
it could be a black person could even be
a Chinese person hell it could be a
white person too there was a few white
slaves you know and everybody knows that
you know I have dreams a lot where I go
back in time and I am like an undercover
slave in the American slave times and
I'm on a you know a ranch or a
plantation and I am you know sent back
in time to help free a lot of slaves and
guide a couple of slaves out of the
plantation and get up to the north and
you know kind of just get things on more
of an appositive track and a lot of the
slaves are on board but there's always
this one slave and this is just a dream
this is a real life there's always this
one slave that won't come you know this
one slave he does not want to come with
me and so that's
it's a dream I've had a few times and
it's always a battle because he doesn't
trust me you know and Here I am trying
to help in this slave lilac is the
slaves name and he does not trust me and
so that's sometimes hard to deal with
even in my dreams to not be trusted but
anyhow I don't know what I was talking
about buddy I was in New York and and
and we had a good time and the British
came out and I just felt like sometimes
that if I meet a friend of the future
who has an issue about you know slavery
or mistreatment of black black people in
America a lot of times the British
persons to be there to handle that
conversation with you if you're just a
regular white person because I didn't do
anything you know I mean my mother was
from the north and her family were
first-generation here and my father was
from Nicaragua so he was
first-generation on that side
I was so anyhow I just sometimes she
liked the British don't take a lot of
responsibility for the the dismay and
some of the just the rape and everything
that they caused around the world I
don't know why I got off on that outside
of that had a good time in New York City
sorry to start off on a low note there
but that's just you know I guess some
things that were on my head you know I
don't have any news for you guys this
week
as far as news goes like topical news
because I just can't stand it anymore
you know everything in the news is just
dismal its dismal you know it's just
attacking anything I feel like most of
the news is just attacking anything
that's you know American and I know it's
hard to find a sense of what is American
these days but I don't think it helps
when the news is just out for money and
not out to communicate with people or to
bring people reliable information
anymore
it's crazy I mean it's really crazy that
we are at a time where we're almost post
truth where anything is fair game these
days you know I mean 20 years ago you
sat at the news you sat at
television to get the facts and now you
and people could can say that well those
weren't the facts and that was all
[ __ ] and this and that and there
could be truth to that but it was most
of what was said was universally agreed
upon and now did it's all entertainment
television I mean I don't think anybody
cares about getting us the facts anymore
and in some ways it's kind of nice it's
like finally I'm free from all of this
[ __ ] because none of it is true
anymore none of it or you don't know
what the truth is so it's kind of nice
just to be away from it you know the
problem is there's so much more access
to it now so in a lot of ways I don't
find myself addicted to the actual
information but I do find myself
addicted to my phone to my computer and
addicted to accessing it if that makes
any sense man I hope it does I'm trying
to make sense guys it's one of my
original goals here that is one of my
original goals here what else is going
on we got some great calls that came in
man a lot of people hit the hotline we
got an issue about honesty we'll have a
last-minute call about a little bit of
young fellow who's been jerking it a
little too much and having some problems
with his [ __ ] and stuff out there and
his activity we got a man called in
about some movies you wants to know
about movies so we are going to get
directly into the hotline first I'm
gonna tell you guys about some dates
here I will be in Stark County Illinois
this Friday night June 30th that is a
fundraiser for a defunct local theater
it's a theater I saw my first movie pink
Cadillac as a child and this will be the
second time I've ever been in the
theater and now I'm there having the the
privilege to help perform and raise some
funds there to get that theater back on
its feet so everybody's really excited
and that's in rural Illinois but it
could be close to you if you live in
Illinois look up Stark County and come
on out that's this Friday night two
shows 7:00 and 9:00 p.m. we're getting
close to sold-out
so I feel really fortunate about that
July 7th and 8th I'll be in Nashville at
Zanies I'll be at the Orlando improv
July 13th through the 16th I'll be in
San Diego July 20th at the House of
Blues with Sal Vulcano from Impractical
Jokers and Roy Wood jr. from The Daily
Show as well i will be in addison texas
august 10th through 13th and september
6th through 9th in Austin and Cleveland
at hilarities September 21st through
24th you can find all of those dates on
Theo von comm slash tour as well you can
get the album 30 pound bag of hamster
bones and the other album musket fire
both of those are available on iTunes
Haley Joel Osment is now 29 years old
you remember the young man from The
Sixth Sense from pay it forward wow what
a movie that was and he will be on the
allegedly podcast my other podcasts that
I have with Matthew Cole Weiss it's more
Hollywood stuff and you can check that
out it will come out on Tuesday and
that's our hundredth episode of that
very grateful to Matthew for all of his
effort and hard work all right let's get
into some questions right here we've got
some amazing ones on the hotline man I'm
so grateful again the hotline number is
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three I'll post it on my Instagram
this week as well so you can always
reference there to check it out
but let's get into to some calls right
here this is from Santa Ana here we go
hey Theo this is Jeremy in Santa Ana I
love that you just allow and even
encourage people to call in and just
talk about anything that's on their mind
I have a question Thank You Jeremy and I
appreciate the calls you know I want to
let you guys know that I appreciate the
fact that you guys meet me halfway and
share
your feelings and thoughts let's keep it
going baby boy I have to preface it by
telling you a quick story ok er today I
was chatting with an acquaintance about
movies specifically a movie from the mid
90s called phenomenon it's a movie
starring John Travolta where he walks
out of a bar one night and he gets
struck by lightning Oh interesting man
I've never been struck but you know that
I was electrocuted recently and and so
this he's kind of hits home man you know
it feels makes me kind of rattles me a
little bit and keeps my neck straight
onward and after that he can speed-read
he does telekinesis and he even finds a
lost child in an apple orchard ooh
every pedophiles a favorite story huh
onward so you know my ten year old brain
went nuts when I saw that and after that
I wanted to have those superpowers so I
wanted to get struck by lightning so for
the next couple of months uh every time
it would rain I remember going outside
and standing underneath the power lines
hoping to get struck but luckily it
never happened and so my question is I
was just wondering if there was ever a
movie or movies from your childhood or
really any point in your life that
changed your paradigm or your mindset or
just kind of influenced you in some sort
of way
awesome man I appreciate I appreciate
your call in your question you had the
family man that's one that comes to mind
of a scene at the end where he stops the
girl at the airport
I mean it's a Nicolas Cage movie it's
one where he kind of gets to see his
life if he had made a different choice
man that scene makes me feel bro when he
stops her at the airport I mean he's
just being so brave he's putting it all
on the line you know he's just he's
saying everything he wants to to this
woman and I guess that you know to care
about a woman enough to chase her down
you can barely do that these days
without somebody would you know trip you
or shoot you or you would be a creep
almost but to chair to care enough to
chase a woman down at the airport
because you want that real love because
you want to you want to go back and time
to make the right choice that that
resonated with me a ton family man you
know because sometimes I guess I wonder
in my own life you know being out here
in Hollywood you sacrifice a lot and I
know it sounds maybe ridiculous to
people who don't live here who aren't in
the entertainment industry but so many
of my friends have been married who have
had children have passed away and I
wasn't able to be there for like they're
these important moments in their life or
in their you know introduction to the
afterlife
so that weighs on you after a while you
know because you you just kind of
sacrifice a lot of that and really it's
selfish you're just selfish so you're
out here being selfish so I guess that's
why that movie resonates with me because
it's like man maybe if I had made a
different choice at a certain time of my
life you know for love or something that
maybe I'd be in a different place in my
heart I might not be in a different
place in my in my ego and in my art but
I might be in a different place in my
heart so that resonated a lot that movie
another one curly sue want to remember
that movie it's about where a girl like
a little girl gets to sleep in a nice
house one night and I remember watching
that when I was a kid and just thinking
about what that would be like to not be
poor just for one night you know in this
film they had um excuse me they had big
bathrobes and this girl you know and
obviously you know I can't relate to
this little girl she's a dying girl you
know a young female child you know a
child with a female parts
but I could relate to being a child and
I remember we're kids watching this and
I was like hottest want to be in that
even just the bathroom or worse you got
to stay with this fancy lawyer that they
met and then she has his first night in
this room and she has her own room and
she's jumping on the beds and just it
resonated with me maybe wonder what it
felt like to be safe - because the girl
seemed so safe in that moment the little
kid she seems so safe in that moment
where she's kind of in this home so
that's kind of pretty much a gay story
for me to tell but that's that's kind of
how I felt and also just I remember she
got to bathe in like a big tub and they
had fancy soaps and music playing in the
background and I know it's just a movie
but that was a moment that really stuck
with me let me think about what else
dream team they just have a movie called
dream team that my siblings and I
watched when we were young we had one of
those video things where you get a
subscription you know you get six movies
for a dollar and then you have to buy 40
movies over the next 7 years or they
take your they take your mom to jail and
we got into that program and this movie
was about like a group of crazy guys in
a mental health institution that get to
go to a baseball park and and it just
seemed like like these guys got to have
one day where they weren't in their
environment you know because at this
point these men were mental they were
mentals you know and you know [ __ ] O's
or whatever people call them I don't
call them names like that I would say
you know mentally unhealthy I might say
retards if I was around some people that
didn't care if I said it but otherwise I
wouldn't just be yelling retards out of
a bus or anything at these type of
people you know I wouldn't do that
but these men were mentally handicapped
and they get to have a day where they're
not in the facility and the interesting
thing is because one of the problems
with the mental health facility is that
after a while of being in there you
become acclimated to being in a mental
health facility
you know like you become more of a
mental health patient what I mean is
like if you take say you take a wild
animal you put them in a cage after a
while it will eventually become you know
a caged animal it won't trust its wild
instincts as much because it's only keen
to using caged instincts and and being
an occasion vironment so it was
interesting to see these men who
probably weren't as mental patient as
they really seemed but because they'd
been in a mental health facility so long
they were more acclimated to that than
they were to being out in the regular
world and it's about for mental health
guys that get tickets to a baseball game
and they sneak out of the facility and
they go have one more day in the outside
world and it's pretty magical pretty
magical man let me think of another one
Oh Cinderella man that one always hit me
in the heart and if you have a film this
will be something to talk about for next
week hit the hotline if there was a
moment in a movie that resonated with
you so much
you know just share it man throw it you
know throw it on your up put it on that
share skillet and warm it up you know
I'd love to hear it
but Cinderella man when James J Braddock
dude the boxer he's in the final fight
you know for all the marbles and he's
bruised and he's beaten and he's you
know bleeding out and his kidneys are
just you know just just would suck his
own cat to get out of the fight I mean
there's his body's just done and then
they cut to his wife you know and she's
played by I want to say Sigourney Weaver
but I'm wrong because I don't know a lot
of actors uh what was she dated Kenny
Chesney but they cut to his wife and
here he is getting beaten him just all
this and she's sitting there listening
to the fight on a radio and they you
know she's been taking care of the kids
they haven't had any food they've only
been having like broth and like bones
and like rat tails and stuff like that
for snacks and then you date and somehow
she is being stronger than he is
I looked that makes any sense but here
he is fighting getting beaten and he's
in an 11th and
all around or whatever and they cut to
the wife and she's just been having to
endure all this and uphold this family
at the same time and somehow you get
this feeling that she is being stronger
than he is and that just really
resonated with me as much you know I
guess I you know when I have a family
like that where the father is is putting
it all on the line and the mother is
somehow you know doing the same thing
you know just that you know she isn't
mum you know my wife wouldn't have to be
in a dirty stairwell and holding on to
some starving children but just I guess
I just wished for that as a kid you know
to have a father that was out there
fighting for us you know even not even
physically just out there hustling to
make some money for us and a mother that
that you know that loved him and to be
able to see that you know because I
didn't see a lot of that growing up I
didn't see any of that love between
parents when I saw my father kissed my
mother one time on a forehead and she
didn't seem super pleased about it that
was in my birthday as well but uh-oh the
last one leap of faith that's right leap
of faith that's a great movie it's about
Steve Martin and they travel around and
they go into these small towns and he's
he's like a preacher he's like a tent
preacher you know like a revival tent
preacher and it's a scam that they're
running but they find one boy in this
one town who's crippled you know his
body isn't doing everything it's
supposed to do his body's taking it
easier you know it his body isn't as you
know it's not really like a party body
it's more of like a you know kind of a
not even trying to turn up really all of
his elements aren't trying to turn up
together some of his body parts are
trying to do different stuff and not
being part of the program crippled and
somehow this boy walks and it like kind
of turns everything of see Martin new
one to his head but anyhow those are
some man those are some to me what else
dude
so I appreciate it those are some of
mine if you guys have some hit the
hotline with them and we'll throw you
guys up some of you guys is up next week
this call right here man
interesting let's just get into it here
we go
hey yo its Alan here I wanted to get you
a appendage story now this is Alan and
he said he wanted to get an appendage
story because we've been we talked about
appendages a few weeks ago
onward Alan I had a few weeks ago you I
haven't heard one so it's a little
different I got arms and legs all that
but he's fully armed in leg alan is on
word me and my father were born without
testicles and i'm going to stop there
for just a second so you can hear it now
Alan and his father were born without
testicles balls nuts and that it is a
cameraman the name of it but it's it's a
common it's a common thing that happens
crypto cryptorchidism it's called and it
can be genetic just so you know so it's
not uncommon for that to happen more
than once inside of a familial genetic
chain let's hear a little bit more about
this nut this nut allergy if you will in
your family onward it's called
understanding the testicle or it's up
inside so well understand a testicle
that's when you got a you already you
got a ball in the corner pocket but you
know that you can't get out if you ever
put money into a pool machine but
sometimes you got to shake a ball out of
there
very similar to what happened here with
Alan and his father you get a nut that
doesn't come out of your body because
your body supposed to spit two nuts out
of here in your nut sack
after you're born sometime and Alan only
got one spit out just to clarify for you
guys sorry to interrupt you Alan know
one word in high school I got an escape
board accident and I got credit carded
where you'll and terrible with the
skateboard between your legs well I went
to the doctor and they said well yeah
you need to get that taken out and still
up there I fell [ __ ] so we had to get it
removed
and she got that off taking care of in
high school so why
all did I can't even in high school like
I would I was kind of paranoid if like
you know if people knew that I was
wearing the same jeans a couple days in
a row and you had to go with a nut you
know with an you know you had to go into
a nut thing and get the nut taken out I
can't even imagine how scared it was
because you probably can't tell anybody
let's find out um they look a little
awkward you nod and tell anybody because
a high schools not a good time to tell
anybody but yeah we had a few high
schools not a good time to tell anybody
anything bro like you told a high school
is the best place to start a rumor
because it could just be insane I
remember it like freshman year we all
went on some camping trip and I told
everyone that Jay Leno had died just for
fun you know to kind of have everybody
give somebody people things to talk
about think about over the weekend and I
was hoping that you know some one of the
young ladies would be like a big Jay
Leno fan and I could swoop in and
consoler you know be that kind of
soldier you feel me but but it just
ended up with a lot of people talking
about how he died and then people kind
of thought I was weird when they found
out he was still alive let's keep going
we had a friend in school his name was
half-sack they talk [ __ ] to him all the
time
I kept my mouth shut but yeah you know I
have a daughter so let's get listen to
that again I'm sorry I stepped on his
toes over high school uh not a good time
to tell anybody but yeah we had a friend
in school his name was half-sack they
talk [ __ ] to him all the time I kept my
mouth shut but yeah you know I have a
daughter so everything works downstairs
but I never had a problem with the women
they don't have really noticed that [ __ ]
I guess I've never had no problems but
uh-huh
that's interesting because women are
usually pretty perceptive but I guess
maybe if you got the [ __ ] out then
they're not thinking about the nuts that
much or maybe if you
be great to interview seven or eight
women who have been with men and only
have one testi or one ball and see if
they noticed you know maybe find a girl
who is willing to hook up with eight or
ten or twelve guys you know make sure
two of the guys only have one ball or
one testicle
and then see how that works you know if
it really if she's able to latch on to
the fact that she's spending time with
the you know with the nutless or with
people with uh you know just one chunk
of caviar down there if you will let's
hear the New York all yeah I just want
to get that to you I dig your comedy and
I love your your wizard works brother
thank you for the compliment I
appreciate it yeah now that's
interesting man because you had to deal
with that nut you know now when you show
up to a place I wonder and I'd love for
you to call back and drop a little bit
more knowledge on me if you can if
you're hearing me out there did you feel
like less of a man showing up with one
nut because I've had two nuts my whole
life and I have I have often felt like
less of a man
even with two nuts you know just felt
like uh you know I've shared a lot of
that in on this podcast just you know
feeling less than and you know like I'm
not worthwhile and that I'm worthless so
I wonder if that drops even more when
you only if those levels drop even lower
when you only have one nut or one
testicle down there in your sack and
also how does it feel is it fun you know
are there girls that will put that into
their mouth and enjoy that is that you
know is there anything unique or any
trickery you can do with just one that
you that's probably tougher to do with
too I bet there's something that US men
with too aren't thinking about it
recognizing so if you could drop a
callback in and let me know more about
that uh that onl baby that one nut life
I would be pleased I'd be really pleased
with that alright let's go to this next
call right here this is Mike
KAC oh my name is Mike I live in
Milwaukee so I've had this concept for a
really good youtube channel for a while
now and uh but I'm nervous to start it
only because there's a high learning
curve on certain video editing skills
that I need to make the videos uh I've
tried different business ideas in the
past but after the exciting idea part
I'm now going at following through on
them my question is this okay so so
Mike's had some business ideas he's had
good ideas before he's not good at
following through on them his question
is this onward in terms of work ethic
how do you Co follow through on the
difficult work when whenever you have
good ideas and the fun part of
developing the idea is over alright does
my question thanks brother by 50 good
question it's a good question because
yeah the fun parts over right after the
creativity the fun parts over for you
and me it is Mike for you and me it is
but for other people it's not other
people their fun starts when they're
presented with a project where they can
delve in and get working on it it's
funny a friend of mine sent me an email
last year about some things I should
check out and one of them is called the
cold test and you can check it out
online it's like 50 bucks
ko LBE and then the letter a kolbe a and
there's a cold B test as well and you
have to be really serious you want to
take this test it's just something you
do online it takes probably about 30-40
minutes but it'll help you understand
what type of person you are
like if you're a creative person or if
you are a follow through type of person
or if you're better at organizing or
you're better at assigning tasks to
others how you receive work from others
there's just a lot of questions that are
that are pieced together to give you
scores to help you figure that figure
out exactly your answer to this Mike so
I recommend that you take that it's
worth the investment and and
in I recommend that if you just if you
find out you're a creative guy then you
have to find someone who is a producer
you got to find somebody who's a who who
can package and put something together
on the other side you stuffed willing to
do a lot of work but you don't but you
don't to do all the work but you're
going to share in some of the reward but
I'll say this I've never I've never
achieved anything in my life alone even
though my ego wants to me to think that
I have you know my ego wants me to think
that I'm a good comedian you know my ego
wants me to think that you know I'm a
mom I was a good athlete and in high
school or in junior high school but the
truth is that I'm only good if I get to
watch other people be good and I get to
learn from them I'm only good if I've
had experiences to be around other
people I'm only good if I have an agent
that can help me get onto certain stages
you know it there always has to be some
teamwork you know this podcast only
comes out because there's a man named
sure you know who takes the audio at
midnight on Sunday and Supes it all up
and who jumps onto the phone with me you
know to go over things and have a little
bit of a plan because there's a man
named camera to put together some art
pieces and and also you know helps go
over some words you know because there's
my assistant Ken it helps package it up
and piece a video together for YouTube
so yeah you just can't do it alone but
that cold
a test will help you out KO LBE anybody
you can go find it but then it's just
recognizing man this is what I'm good
this is what I'm not and honourably
taking it on and realizing what your
skills are because otherwise you can
spend your whole life fighting against
your own abilities you know and my ego
wants me to do it all but the reality is
that I can't do it all man I can barely
do a third of it usually so that's why I
got to incorporate other people and in
the end man it is I'm really feeling
better when you do something with other
people so I
find some it's a good producer that
wants to pop off and uh and I think
you'll probably achieve some of these
ideas Mike appreciate you calling let's
get one more call right here because I
have a I got a sore throat guys so I'm
probably going to drop it down a little
bit early this evening but I appreciate
you guys hitting the hotline let's hit
one more call right here hey it's
Brandon from Salt Lake City just wanted
to ask you something Theo you brought up
in your last episode about pornography
sexual addiction I want to dive into
that these young men being in my early
twenties is one of that what's the best
I do an animal situation when you're
going to pornography masturbation not
for like the sexual urge just more
because you're getting down on yourself
a life's getting tough and what's the
best way to bounce back out of it
appreciate you man well I appreciate
this call and a lot of you guys are like
well we've talked about this before
we've answered it before but I'm gonna
throw some skin in the game man
you know I've been back struggling with
it myself man you know and I wish I had
a great answer for you I do know that
you just can't get too down on yourself
if you're able to recognize that it is
an action if you you spraying out or you
you know you spit in life out of your
[ __ ] or penis with just because you want
to find some joy inside of yourself or
because you want to feel better at least
you're recognizing that you know that's
part of it the part of it is realizing
that you're not just doing it for some
type of sensual joy anymore you know
that you're doing it because you there's
some other gratification that goes on
you know and it's not even a positive
gratification it's just sometimes to get
you out of a depression or to get you
through a fit of a feeling or a vangor
or sometimes a feeling you don't even
understand and you know I all I can tell
you is you're not alone man you know
I've been having trouble over the past
couple of weeks especially you know when
I start and we talked about elastic a
little about commitment when I start
talking about that commitment man
man I feel this other side of me act up
that you know goes to pornography and
goes to those types of things you know
it's just something there's something
wrong in me so what do I need to do well
I can tell what I need to do for me for
me I probably need to go and talk to a
therapist about it so so I need to do
that I was supposed to do that last week
and I didn't do it you know because
that's part of something inside of me
that wants to just not take care of me
you know this sometimes this sometimes
sometimes you you want to take care
yourself but to someone in society that
does not want to you know and that's the
part that you got to fight so I just say
man don't don't feel that shame you know
just because you do that that's not who
you are you know just because you might
watch too much pornography or be
addicted to masturbating or suffering in
that sense you're not a bad person you
know that's just some little illness or
sickness that you have to porn they're
making out there I mean this is Vietnam
this is this is the Vietnam a
pornography going on these days because
it's heavy that stuff this stick this
isn't the pornography they found you
need to know we found some nudie
magazines in the woods when I was a
child you notice a couple jerk stacks
you know when someone had already been
jerked on or whatever we got them out
and that was more passive you know that
was just and even that was so vivid back
then think about how vivid the first
pornography ever saw was damn that thing
was hot I remember the magazines even
felt hot in my hand because it was so
vivid and now here we are the stuff that
we got now it's a war out there man so
just once you know you know you're not
alone with it man I'm out there fighting
it too cuz I'll probably got to check in
with a couple of friends this week who
suffer with it as well do because
there's some time you know I will say
this if you can commit to quitting you
can find a way to commit to quitting you
will start feeling differently about
yourself man and that is that's the
truth so good luck out there with that
and I might even leave you
I'm going to take some listener advice
right here some listeners called it with
some of their thoughts on the same topic
there so here you go Casey oh it's
Nathan years from Detroit Michigan arm
just wanna state and this do it if he's
calling it about masturbation from
Detroit
that's some serious masturbation I mean
you ducking slugs out there you know and
gangbangers and still jerking off I mean
it's really hard to hide from gunfire
and and find some decent nut activity at
the same time onward they thank you for
your comedy than bringing a lot of
solidarity and joy to me since I find
John the Joe Rogan podcast just wanted
to say I've been struggling with
masturbation forever man and is a cool
subreddit called no SAP that I'm
encouraging you might too but I really
saw the seeded as of late and I can have
you know a really great day or a really
bad day but if I'm alone at the end of
the night don't have the will not to man
you hit it on the head dude I know we've
talked about it before we have a lot of
new listeners and I want them to know
that this is a safe ground where they
can share anything man and if I have
skin in the game you know literally I'll
put my skin in the game man let's listen
to a little bit more of this because
that's exactly what it is maybe you just
don't have that control at a certain
point in the evening the willpower you
know I I just feel like we're
genetically programmed to need to you
know survive and produce so I don't know
if it's worth it to fight you know
mother nature thanks again man well I
say it to that to that final part of
your call there just hold the line my
man you know don't don't don't feel
defeated we stay in this together and
you gave some great advice there and
that's called no fat calm nof AP dot C
Oh M that's a great website to help
battle it man because you can be out
there having fun sometimes you know when
you get in perky with yourself but other
times it can be they can be slippin into
the dark hearts you know back into the
dirty bellybutton of the devil
and I'm going to hit you off here with
one more actually one more caller there
that's going to be on the same topic
here kind of the same topic
this guy is offering some ideas of if
you have too much idle time on your
hands because that's some of the things
some time with me in the evening when
I'm you know I get home and I relax and
then my mind starts want to be naughty
because your mind sometimes it's just
that kid it's just that wild child and
if you got free time that wild child
will take control of your hands and do
whatever he wants he kind of becomes
that Geppetto you know when you got
those Pinocchio palms and he starts
moving your hands and doing usually wild
things with the penis or with other
stuff you know so this guy had some
unique thoughts if you got idle time
here you go
a Pheo I was just watching your YouTube
video and you were talking about a
little about getting older and you know
not partying so much and not drinking
and a lot of older guys they started
getting more into their hobbies and the
top three hobbies right now are like you
know refurbishing or building old cars
building firearms like they are they are
15 and building computers like for games
or multitasking dang did I think this
guy wants to be a mobster doesn't it
sound like it I mean this is this is
wild to me I appreciate the call I
appreciate 100 percent do when you set
building firearms
I guess that's wild to me but that could
be part of my brain to just telling me
everything's stupid so that it can keep
just using my hands to do whatever it
wants so those are three things let's
hear a little bit more about them and
Terry Crews is famous for getting into
the gaming scene and people the whole
gaming PC and these are things with a
very low barrier to entry mm-hmm and uh
so anyone can get into them but they're
also kind of difficult technical and
people have to overcome you you know
these challenges and it doesn't focus so
much on people you know it's a little
bit more technical oriented and calms a
lot of people down and get you thinking
more in the like art artsy kind of terms
and the mathematical terms and a lot of
people like to do this in their old time
old age and my neighbor was doing maybe
Arizona air 15 and he built like anyway
you know he's doing target shooting or
3-gun competition he's older guy you
know I'm gonna stop at there your
neighbor could be a straight-up killer
dog I will say that but you're right I
mean it's it's about finding things to
do and about finding things to do that
to keep us busy and also to challenge
our mind in a new way and that would be
another answer for the guy that called
in saying in Utah that he was you know
jerking out up there at that high
altitude you know and I can't even
imagine masturbating at high altitude
you know it's just seem like it would
really just dehydrate you quickly but
that's something you know those are some
things you could do refurbish a car
build a gun though the computer I mean
those are intense things but I think the
idea there is just challenge yourself to
something new and start to reprogram
your brain as to what some of your
habits are those are the thoughts of
mine man but I struggle with it too man
I'm still out of here struggling you
guys hit the hotline get back to me
suddenly down here a little get a little
bit sick in the in the trick I'll see
you guys at some of the upcoming shows
and I'll be back this week I might do
another episode maybe on Thursday if I'm
feeling a little bit better and I can
get into more of the calls I really
appreciate you guys being here this week
I know this wasn't the longest episode
but but uh but I'm just happy that we
got to do it I really am appreciate you
guys staying with me and staying onboard
I'll see you guys next time on this past
weekend
you do
it never came in
you got to celebrate it all man you're
going to try this is what we got for now
guys you know we got each other now we
keep reaching out we do man as long as
we keep reaching out you guys do good to
yourselves man you probably deserve it
thank you for your time I'm Theo von
this is this past weekend